when I consume television when I consume  reality shows I mean I cannot tell you  how many times I see a guys just  castrated I mean it's it's acceptable  for guys to be figuratively castrated on  television it's celebrated it's  celebrated by women they cheer I talked  about The Bachelorette on here I mean it  was disgusting what they did to that guy  on national television and I think it's  really hard for young men to feel like  they're now in a society where it's like  I'm the bad guy on day one no matter  what I'm expected to do all of these  things or I'm not considered valuable  you know I can't have any expectations  of a woman or I'm I'm deemed  misogynistic uh there's a society that  actively wants to villainize me  immediately I think that can be very  crippling and my advice to men is always  work on yourself you know get into the  gym get your endorphins running take  care of yourself you know get a good job  you'll feel good about yourself